you don't worry this dinosaur might look
dangerous but it's perfectly harmless
some clever hand movements bring this
featherweight creature to life it's one
of many finger puppets made by Barnaby
Dixon the young man from Bridgewater in
southwestern England makes his puppets
by hand
Deb chick the duck was his first
creation for me that the puppets I'd
seen before more traditional puppets
didn't really have the same kind of
fluidity and gravity as as you're able
to obtain with stop-motion so the result
of stop-motion was kind of my starting
point and I just think I was thinking
how can I make live-action puppets have
the same sort of realism as as
stop-motion characters
the special thing about Barnaby's
puppets is that though they are built
around his hands
they aren't glove puppets his latest
character is Manu Barnaby can perform
intricate movements that look amazingly
lifelike
[Music]
Barnaby often spends time in his
workshop perfecting his puppets the
joints are made of metal the bodies are
made of a combination of resin silicon
and plastic he buys all his materials
online
[Music]
one of the main challenges in building
these puppets is you've got kind of two
starting points one that is the kind of
ideal puppet that you want to create but
then you also have to accommodate for
your own hands and the asymmetry and the
way that they move in a way that you
wouldn't kind of imagine sometimes so I
think trying to marry those two things
and finding something that works in
terms of proportion but also in terms of
movement and also in terms of aesthetic
is tricky Barnaby Dixon has his puppets
perform everyday situations on YouTube
dab cheek the duck always plays the lead
role he posts a new video every week he
endowed cheek now have some 150,000
subscribers ah the great British seaside
to feel the salty breeze rush through my
feathers soft wet sand oh joy of joys
unless we forget the proud URI of the
waves
thundering 2l4 I'd like to go home now
please
however interesting your puppets are
whatever technical skill you show in
their creation the character of the
puppet is what makes people fall in love
with them to some degree or or at least
want to come back for more
Barnaby Dixon also shows his puppets in
local pubs
he likes keeping in close contact with
his fans and not only virtually I think
it's nice to show that show the puppets
to the public because you get a sense of
the reception for through YouTube
comments and through you know people
liking it and things like that but you
don't really get a sense of you know
people's faces when they see it and and
you when when I see people's reactions
and it's a positive one in the flesh you
know there's something different about
that that the type that I value the main
attraction tonight is a special dance
performance manu glows in the dark and
Dixon's hands become almost invisible
riveting stuff for the audience
[Music]
location you look at your fingers it's
like moving by itself you kind of forget
about the hands and you just you just
you just focus on this this puppet I
just couldn't believe how much I lost
myself in in the character of the piece
with the birds you feel like it's moving
in a way that a real birds or animal
would move in with the dinosaurs
obviously you know no one's seen a
dinosaur but I feel like that's how a
dinosaur moves
Barnaby Dixon is already working on new
characters but for now mono is enjoying
his time in the limelight